bonsoir avec quelques petites secondes
de retard je vous prie de nous en
excuser édition complète du journal à 1h
quelque peu inhabituelle football oblige
à la fin de ce journal nous reviendrons
sur ce match de coupe d'europe
en vous présentant les buts les quatre
buts qui ont permis à duisbourg de se
qualifier aux dépens de strasbourg pour
les quarts de finale de la coupe de
l'uefa
tout de suite les autres titres de
l'actualité avec pour commencer la fin
hier soir à bruxelles du conseil
européen décidément ce n'est pas facile
de faire l'europe et ce nouveau sommet
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement l'a
démontré une fois de plus en principe
tout le monde est d'accord pour la
création d'un système monétaire européen
lorsqu'on commence à parler des détails
et bien cela accroche la grande bretagne
dit non merci pas pour l'instant
l'italie et l'irlande demande à
réfléchir car on ne leur a pas accordé
les aides qu'elle demandait seule la
france l'allemagne fédérale les trois
pays du benelux et le danemark ont
accepté immédiatement et sans réserve de
participer à partir du 1er janvier
prochain au nouveau système monétaire
européen
en résumé les neuf se retrouve à six
pour stabiliser leur monnaie pour
monsieur giscard d'estaing c'est tout de
même la mort d'un véritable système
monétaire pour l'europe c'est ça mais
bien placé c'est le point que ton de
nombre puisque tout dépend de la vigueur
des économies et des bonnets des prix en
question et je considère chelsea pays
il décide d'y participer sont capables
de faire vivre un tel système
le caractère du système en effet sera
différent suivant qu'il sera si ce qu'il
sera ainsi les tanneurs fils ingrat car
tu te fais communautaire s'il est à 6 le
même dispositif prend la forme d'un
accord entre des les six états membres
et c'est après la réponse des ceux qui
n'ont pas encore fait connaître leur
décision nous aurons à nous prononcer
sur ce point le 1er janvier prochain il
y aura donc une robe monétaire avec les
six pays qui apparaît sur cette carte la
france l'allemagne la belgique la
hollande luxembourg et le danemark deux
autres pays l'italie et l'irlande ont
réservé pendant quinze jours leur
réponse est pour l'instant la grande
bretagne refuse entrer dans le système
elle changera peut être d'avis après les
élections alors pourquoi cette phase r
philippe creissen et bien à l'italie et
l'irlande de demander une aide
financière plus important que prévu afin
de muscler leur économie leur permettre
d'adhérer au système monétaire alors la
pièce centrale du système mis en place
hier celi q qu'est ce que cela
représente exactement je vais goûter
c'est les beaufs d'une future monnaie
européenne les culs est composé des
monnaies des neuf villes communautés
ce cocktail vaut actuellement environ
580 mais à quoi ça va servir exactement
ctq laissez les cuire à d'abord une
valeur de référence
et c'est par rapport à l'écu qu'on
jugera suis plus une monnaie montent ou
baissent trop ensuite les culs deviendra
peu à peu un moyen de paiement entre les
banques centrales européennes mais vous
n'aurez jamais vécu dans votre poche
malgré son nom ce n'est pas une pièce de
monnaie
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer de
façon simple comment est-ce que ça va
fonctionner maintenant ce nouveau
système
d'abord point important à noter à partir
d'une certaine variation d'une monnaie
chaque pays devra en principe prendre
des mesures de politique économique et
se concerter avec les autres pays pour
corriger les écarts ce signal d'alarmé
devrait permettre d'éviter des crises
monétaires trop grave mais au delà des
mécanismes techniques
c'est cette volonté de coordonner les
politiques économiques qui peut
améliorer la situation économique de
l'europe et pour la france alors
qu'est-ce que cela va changer qu'est ce
que cela représente concrètement vient
d'abord pour les agriculteurs cela
signifie le retour progressif à la
stabilité et à l'unité des prix
agricoles en europe mais c'est aussi
important pour toute l'économie français
c'est ce qu'a expliqué hier soir
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
pas de bourse et je dirais l'entrée dans
la vie des français d'une vieille idée
et qui le fait que l'europe aura une
monnaie progressivement commune on lui a
donné d'ailleurs un nom français ce
n'est pas un hasard donc il voulu que ce
soit un nom français c'est les culs le
vieux nom de l'abonné de saint louis et
qui donc après siècle
elle retrouvera en europe l'actualité et
j'espère une réputation favorable donc
le premier objectif c'est créer une zone
de stabilité monétaire en europe et que
ceux qui achètent et qui vendent en
europe et je savais qu'ils sont très
nombreux dans notre économie sache à
quel prix ils achètent à quel prix ils
vendent sans être obligé de consulter
les jours les fluctuations des cours des
changes
nous pesons à peu près la moitié de
notre commerce extérieur avec nos
partenaires européens et donc pour la
moitié de notre commerce extérieur nous
aurons désormais des prix stables en
même temps le fait d'appartenir à une
zone monétaire started est un facteur de
confiance confiance dans ce que l'on
possède des habitants confiance dans ses
projets d'avenir c'est donc à
l'encouragement à investir et
l'investissement en france et comme vous
savez une des conditions de
l'amélioration de l'emploi donc je
considère que sur le plan de nos
échanges extérieurs sur le plan de notre
investissement et de notre emploi c'est
une décision positive
il faut noter que les marchés des
changes ont bien réagi aujourd'hui et
que le franc était en hausse
je propose maintenant de faire le tour
des principales réactions à cette
création d'un système monétaire européen
à partir du 1er janvier
nous venons donc d'entendre monsieur
giscard d'estaing pour la france
le chancelier ouest allemand helmut
schmidt s'est déclaré convaincu cet
après midi que ceux qui participeraient
à ce nouveau système monétaire en
retireraient des avantages importants
cela va instaurer un climat de confiance
en europe et faciliter une convergence
des politiques économiques c'est un
grand succès at il ajouté alors pour les
trois autres pays qui n'ont pas adhéré à
ce système monétaire les jugements
évidemment sont tout à fait différents
en italie par exemple le délai de
réflexion de huit jours demandé par
monsieur andreotti le président du
conseil s'est ouvert dans une véritable
atmosphère de crise en raison de
l'opposition des socialistes et des
communistes qui normalement soutiennent
le gouvernement mais qui cette fois sont
contre ce système monétaire en irlande
c'est la déception
dublin avait demandé une aide dublin n'a
rien obtenu
les irlandais vont réfléchir maintenant
pendant deux semaines mais ils sont
relativement pessimiste pour la grande
bretagne
claude gaignierre notre correspondant à
londres les anglais pour le moins sont
satisfaits et disent bravo à callaghan
qui a réussi un excellent coup à la fois
politique et diplomatique diplomatique
parce que les anglais n'avaient pas
l'intention d'entrer dans système
monétaire européen
ce qu'il créé c'était d'être isolé ils
ne le sont plus italiens et irlandais
ces cartes aussi du projet justifiant
l'attitude des britanniques et leur
permettant surtout de ne pas porter le
chapeau de la rupture
personne en effet n'attendais que les
anglais participent au projet coup
politique parce que callaghan retourne
au pays ayant bien méritée du parti
travailliste au pouvoir lequel n'est pas
particulièrement pro européen les
élections générales prochaine s'annonce
bien pour le premier ministre
britannique dans quelques minutes de ce
studio à bruxelles la bbc réalisera en
direct une émission sur le sommet et
diers alors peter est ce que j'ai bien
résumer votre impression et l'impression
des anglais très bien réussi résumé mais
dans le sens que vous avez oublié quand
même une large minorité d'entrée qui
sont pour le marché commun qui sont pour
ce système monétaire européen jusqu'à
que eux ils sont un peu déçu quand même
que messieurs karine refusé dès le
sommet de brême même d'y penser
sérieusement à entrer là dedans mais à
part ça je crois que tous les anglais
sont très contents de voir le premier
ministre agir comme ça agit un peu comme
si vous voulez mon général général de
gaulle comme il l'a fait dans le temps
vous voulez dire par là qu'on se soucie
peut-être plus des intérêts nationaux
que des intérêts de la communauté
européenne pour le moment je crois que
les anglais ils aiment bien que qu'un
gouvernement britannique pense plutôt
aux intérêts britanniques aux intérêts
internationaux parce que nous avons
tellement de problèmes ico quand même
résoudre ces problèmes d'abord et
maintenant qu'est ce qui va se passer je
crois que made in dc canada c'est un
conférence de presse hier soir il faut
plutôt penser sérieusement sur cette
politique agricole et aussi pour nos
péchés il faut ci voulait renégocier ces
deux choses là
que de penser vraiment système monétaire
européen à l'assemblée nationale on a
également beaucoup parlé de l'europe cet
après midi on devait au départ
simplement aborder le problème de
l'harmonisation de la tva européenne
que monsieur raymond barre vous l'êtes
inclure dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative la rallonge
budgétaire pour 78 vu finalement
l'événement de la journée ça a été un
peu la lettre que jacques chirac a
envoyé par yves guéna monsieur libyenne
à la lutte devant le conseil politique
du rpr réuni d'urgence
cet après midi daniel hubmann qu'en avez
vous retenu de cette lettre eh bien je
crois qu'il faut séparer deux chaussées
que jacques chirac a joué au pompier
avec les députés et à l'incendiaire avec
les militants alors en début
d'après-midi la dresser une première
lettre au président du groupe rpr claude
labbé pour confirmer la trêve ce qui
permettait en toute bonne conscience au
député rpr de dire qu'il voterait le
texte qu'ils avaient refusé jeudi après
des explications d'une heure du premier
ministre alors évidemment on peut se
dire que le président chirac a pris les
devants et que au fond il savait
parfaitement que les députés rpr ne
voulait pas ouvrir une crise mais cette
tempête parlementaire était à peine
apaisée que jacques chirac cette fois
déclaré la guerre dans un message de
trois pages qui devait être lue devant
le conseil politique et qui s'adressait
en fait aux militants et bien là il le
fait avec une violence d'expression
encore jamais atteinte il dit un non
catégorique à l'europe du président de
la république et je cite non à
l'abaissement de la france et à son
déclin ajoutons comme toujours quand il
s'agit de cette opération le parti de
l'étranger est à l'heure avec sa voix
paisible et rassurante et la lettre se
conclut sur un appel au combat alors je
crois que cette façon si j'ose dire de
reprendre pied avec éclat dans
l'actualité signifie que la campagne
électorale européenne sera difficile et
qu'en tout état de cause il n'y aura pas
de liste très ouverte de la majorité
j'ai à mes côtés bernard stasi qu'est le
vice président du centre des démocrates
sociaux et à qui je vais demander
quelles sont ses premières réactions à
la lecture de cette lettre
oui je crois que
ton de la lettre de jacques chirac
prouve en tout cas que malgré l'accident
il n'a rien perdu de sa fougue et sa
vigueur et de cela il faut se réjouir
mais c'est le seul motif de satisfaction
que nous apporte cette déclaration dans
les termes sont tout de même assez
surprenant
en effet hier les chefs d'état de
gouvernement ont fait franchir un pas
important à l'europe vers son
indépendance monétaire donc libérer de
la tutelle du dollar deuxièmement une
plus grande solidarité monétaire entre
les pays de l'europe créé les conditions
d'une croissance durable et d'un retour
progressif au plein emploi
alors je crois que tous ceux qui
souhaitent l'organisation d'une europe
indépendante et tous ceux qui veulent
que la france sorte le plus rapidement
possible de la crise devraient se
réjouir de ce qui s'est passé hier à
bruxelles et qu'aucune considérations de
politique intérieure devrait prévaloir
dans cette affaire c'est précisément en
tournant le dos à l'europe que la france
tombe raide en cette averse
asservissement économique dont a parlé
jacques chirac dans cette lettre et que
la france disparaîtraient de la scène
internationale en tout cas cette
déclaration que vous lui avez dit daniel
brême laisse présager une campagne
électorale très animé mais je suis sûr
que les français comprendront que le
rassemblement de l'espérance dont parle
jacques chirac c'est le rassemblement de
ceux qui savent que dans le monde
difficile qui une autre il n'y a pas de
salut pour la france sans une plus
grande solidarité européenne merci bien
noël copains on va faire l'analyse un
peu de toutes ces déclarations faites
cet après midi est ce que c'est vraiment
la guerre ou la paix à l'intérieur de la
majorité est ce que d'après vous la
majorité peut éclater mais que fait pour
reprendre les termes employés tout prix
par daniel brême jacques chirac est-il
surtout un pompier vous est-il surtout
un incendiaire j'avoue que ce soir c'est
bien difficile de trancher je crois
quand même que si l'on se pose la
question y aura-t-il une guerre de la
majorité il faut quand même partir de
quelques constatations assez simple
premières constatations le rpr est tenu
par la trêve qu'il a lui-même annoncé le
10 octobre et que jacques chirac
rappelait aujourd'hui et puis après tout
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours en
particulier le vote négatif du rpr la
semaine dernière sur l'harmonisation de
la tva
et puis les cris hostiles à valéry
giscard d'estaing poussé par des jeunes
rpr samedi dernier je crois que le rpr a
compris qu'il y avait deux écueils
de seuil si vous voulez qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas franchir premièrement le
rpr ne peut pas se faire accuser de
mêler ses voix on voit des communistes
avec l'eau de la baie s'est bien défendu
d'avoir agi de cette façon là la semaine
dernière et deuxièmement le rpr ne peut
pas se faire accuser non plus
d'agressions contre le président de la
république alors je crois que malgré le
côté très combatif du langage utilisé
par jacques chirac dans sa lettre à son
conseil politique cet après midi cela
n'annonce pas une rupture au moins pas
dans l'immédiat pourquoi noël copains ce
nouvel accrochage sur l'europe
comment vous l'expliquez bien je crois
qu'il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord des
raisons de deux simples politiques
immédiates
le rpr va donc se lancer et se lancer
sous ses propres couleurs dans une
bataille électorale pour le mois de juin
prochain une bataille qui cède avance
difficile il fait donc un démarrage
assez foudroyant assez bruyant et
deuxièmement la grande inquiétude du rpr
c'était même une sorte d'obsession ç'a
toujours été de se faire possédé par une
manoeuvre d'enveloppement ou de rejet et
qui serait une manoeuvre de changement
de la majorité et il sait que s'il ce
changement de majorité peut se faire ce
pourrait être à propos de l'europe
et puis enfin le style épique du texte
du texte de jacques chirac montre la
volonté du rpr de prendre date sur
l'europe
si vous voulez il veut prendre ses
distances à l'égard de ce que certains
de ses dirigeants emplettes en privé cet
après midi une sorte de nouveau munich
mais alors la question qui se pose c'est
de savoir si et si lorsque on dit que la
france est menacée d'asservissement
ça n'est pas sans commune mesure avec
cette petite trêve parlementaire etc je
crois cette contradiction apparente qui
demeure quand même le fait marquant de
cette journée bien le référendum en
espagne maintenant vous savez que depuis
9h ce matin 25 millions d'espagnols de
plus de 18 ans sont appelés à se
prononcer sur un projet de constitution
le projet qui a déjà un qui a d'ailleurs
été déjà adopté à une écrasante majorité
par le parlement espagnol
le 31 octobre dernier tout s'est passé
dans le calme
le scrutin est terminée depuis près
d'une heure et demi maintenant il y as
selon la première estimation 70 % de
votants il faut remarquer qu'au pays
basque qui à saint sébastien en
particulier en revanche le pourcentage
de votants a été particulièrement faible
les principaux dirigeants politiques
espagnols ont pour la plupart accompli
leur devoir électoral dans la matinée
dans les premiers ayant été le roi juan
carlos
avec son épouse ils font assaut
qui doit légitimer la monarchie en
espagne juan carlos a mis la dernière
main au processus de démocratisation du
pays
processus qu'il a lui-même surveiller
étroitement depuis son accession à la
tête de l'état espagnol il y a trois ans
cette consultation met un terme à la
période de transition post franquiste à
la démocrature comme ont dit certains
espagnols pour nommer ce passage en
douceur de la dictature à la démocratie
le vote des espagnols s'est déroulé sans
incident grave de très important
déploiement policier ont été effectuées
à travers du pays ils n'ont pas empêché
le vol des bulletins de vote par des
groupes d'extrême droite dans des
bureaux madrilène et plusieurs alertes à
la bombe parfois fondées de la veuve du
cardio carmen polo des fringues corps
aux derniers militants d'extrême gauche
le scrutin s'est effectuée sans tension
la participation électorale faible en
fin de matinée semblait s'être accru de
façon notable en fin d'après midi et
jusqu'à 20h les premiers pourcentages de
participation ne seront connus au cours
de la soirée et les résultats seulement
dans la nuit
geste d'apaisement du gouvernement
militaire iranien monsieur karim sent
djabi le président du front national
la principale force d'opposition laïque
mais monsieur samedi a été libérée dans
l'après midi radio téhéran a annoncé
d'ailleurs que sur la demande du chat
120 prisonniers politiques et 3 152
prisonniers condamnés par les tribunaux
militaires allaient être bientôt
relâchés eux aussi délibération qui
devrait quelque peu détendre
l'atmosphère dans les rues de la
capitale calmes pendant la journée mais
qui hier soir encore ont été le théâtre
de manifestations et de fusillades
aujourd'hui en iran ce sont des
centaines de manifestations spontanées
comme celle ci qui se déroule à travers
tout le pays chaque jour au cimetière de
téhéran
on enterre les victimes des heures des
jours précédents et très vite la
contestation politique prend le pas sur
la douleur mais le véritable ciment de
ces contestations le trouve dans les
mosquées qui ne désemplissent pas en
cette période de moharram le grand deuil
chiite
les sermons des ayatollahs se transforme
invariablement de violentes critiques à
l'égard du chat c'est ici qu'on lance
les appels à la grève générale à la
manifestation monstre qui doit avoir
lieu dimanche en présence des plus
hautes instances religieuses du pays
en attendant les iraniens ont trouvé un
nouveau moyen pour affirmer leur
hostilité au régime
chaque soir après le couvre-feu ils
montent sur leur terrasse et lance dans
la nuit de téhéran un cri qui est repris
par des centaines de milliers de voix
allah o akbar dieu est grand et face à
ce genre de manifestation
l'armée ne peut strictement rien écouté
à
de l'étranger encore ces télégrammes
proche orient le premier ministre
égyptien monsieur kabyles se déclare
prêt à rencontrer monsieur moshe dyan le
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères vous savez que le week-end
prochain
cyrus vance le secrétaire d'état
américain par pour le proche orient pour
essayer de débloquer les négociations
entre l'egypte et israël
18 radars volant pour l'otan
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord
ces radars seront répartis d'ici à 1982
le long de la frontière du pacte de
varsovie
l'accord a été signé ce matin à
bruxelles les pays de l'otan aimerait
bien que la france participe à ce
programme de radars volant ne serait ce
que pour réduire les frais
la france n'a pas signé l'accord et elle
elle envisagerait d'ailleurs d'avoir son
propre système au dessus du territoire
la suisse a un nouveau président il
s'agit de monsieur hans hürlimann
il a été élu aujourd'hui le nouveau
président de la confédération helvétique
pour un an il est en même temps ministre
de l'intérieur et puis il y aura bientôt
une université de la paix elle sera
fondée à costa rica la commission
économique de l'assemblée des nations
unies a donné son accord pour que cette
université soit bientôt construite à cet
endroit vous voyez le plan la paix ce
sera le thème principal de l'émission
que prépare la rédaction d'antenne 2
pour le 18 décembre prochain la peine
mission impossible
une question à laquelle nous essaierons
de répondre avec des enquêtes des
reportages aux quatre coins du monde
mais en france aussi pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs s'interroger sur la paix
intérieure
invité de cette émission entre autres le
professeur jankélévitch georges brassens
raymond devos mikis theodorakis rendez
vous donc le lundi 18 décembre à 20h30
ce sera la première grande soirée des
programmes de fin d'année sur un tender
revenons maintenant à l'actualité plus
immédiate avec le retour ce matin à
paris de monsieur jean françois deniau
le ministre français du commerce
extérieur
il rentre de pékin avec dans ses bagages
des accords signés entre la france et la
chine populaire pour une valeur de près
de 60 milliards
et pour une durée de sept ans c'est la
première fois a fait remarquer monsieur
de nyon que la chine signent un accord
pour une aussi longue durée et dans les
textes paraphés à pékin il est dit que
la france allait livrer à la chine de
réacteurs nucléaires construits par
framatome mais sous licence américaine
or précisément les états unis ont
rappelé que leur action était nécessaire
aux gens a publiquement confirmé
l'intention du gouvernement chinois de
commander deux centrales nucléaires à la
france or les chinois ils ont besoin de
nous pour les aider à fabriquer de
l'énergie et électricité parce que tout
est à faire dans cette à bella ils n'ont
absolument pas besoin de nous dans le
domaine militaire chacun sait qu'ils ont
dans le domaine militaire accompli tous
les progrès qu'ils ont là une bombe h
et donc il est clair que notre
coopération dans ce domaine c'est pour
faire de l'électricité et c'est tout à
fait pacifique
dans ces conditions ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup qu'il puisse y avoir des
difficultés sérieuses du côté américain
décidément c'est une période très faste
pour la signature d'accords commerciaux
entre paris et pékin ce matin même à
paris monsieur thien minh ministre
chinois chargé de l'industrie mécanique
le monsieur giraud le ministre français
de l'industrie ont paraphé un protocole
d'accord de coopération industrielle en
électronique et en informatique
l'informatique
il en a été beaucoup question ce matin
au conseil des ministres développant
l'ensemble des mesures arrêtées lors du
conseil restreint sur l'informatique il
ya une semaine
monsieur giraud a expliqué que la france
se donne maintenant cinq ans pour
devenir une nation de pointe dans ce
domaine et surtout pour que les français
se familiarisent avec l'informatique
une agence à être créé pour la diffusion
de ses applications
une enveloppe budgétaire de plus de 2
milliards de francs va être attribué à
ce secteur pour mieux comprendre
l'importance de ce phénomène nous avons
choisi de vous montrer un domaine
nouveau à savoir l'informatique à
l'école il y aura bientôt dix mille
professeurs avec nîmes une machine pour
10000 c es lycée ou collège georges
leclercq a enquêté dans un ellis et
prototypes
nous sommes dans une classe de terminale
d'un lycée de la banlieue sud de paris
un de ses 58 lycée camille au point
l'enseignement avec l'aide de
l'ordinateur
il ne s'agit pas d'apprendre une
nouvelle matière l'informatique comme on
apprend la géographie ou le calcul mais
plutôt d'utiliser l'ordinateur partout
où il peut être utile sous la conduite
d'un professeur de lycée spécialement
formés comme quelques centaines de ses
collègues a habitué les élèves à se
servir de l'ordinateur
olivier c'est difficile de se servir
d'une telle machine
bon il faut pas se tromper puis faut
tout savoir
sinon moindre erreur c'est foutu pour
commencer j'ai travaillé deux jours du
scientisme manceau de la physique bon
goût bout d'une demi heure trois quart
d'heure salée quand j'arrive en sol vous
avez jamais vus l'ordinateur avant non
non donc vous pensez que l'enseignement
avec l'ordinateur c'est très facile à
faire
oui en acquérant des les boss de passe
conçu en fait les élèves et les
professeurs imagine que même les
méthodes d'utilisation des machines dans
les différentes matières
puis les classes les appliquer les
perfectionne ici nous sommes en classe
de français et vous allez le voir
l'ordinateur et la littérature peuvent
très bien faire bon ménage
et on peut surtout lire les textes et
les isoler manipuler dire que les élèves
voient apparaître selon leur demande les
textes des mots du texte des phrases du
texte et la machine elle-même par
conséquent à multiplier les lecture du
texte
nous avons actuellement du programme qui
permette de connaître la fréquence d'un
mot qui permettent de connaître sa
répartition dans un texte qui permettent
de mesurer la longueur des phrases
ces efforts ne sont pas isolés
l'éducation nationale les regroupe les
met en forme les diffusent dans les
autres lycées équipés d'ordinateurs et
déjà voit plus loin notamment ce qui
concerne le matériel
cette machine est implanté dans le lycée
depuis 1973 et il est évident qu'en 1973
cette machine était parfaitement adapté
à ce qu'on voulait lui faire faire en
cinq ans la technologie a beaucoup
évolué et maintenant ce genre de machine
est dépassé il existe maintenant des
mini ordinateurs qui coûte beaucoup
moins cher et qui sont deux à trois fois
plus puissant et vous pensez qu'il
rendrait les mêmes services au moins que
ce que vous êtes en train de rendre aux
élèves aujourd'hui c'est évident qu'il
rendrait les mêmes services même
peut-être plus reste un énorme problème
cette classe américaine est un symbole
les petits ordinateurs viennent surtout
des états unis et parle qu'anglais
alors il faut très vite organiser notre
industrie pour produire des
micro-ordinateurs en grand nombre et
surtout leur apprendre le français
toujours au conseil des ministres de ce
matin adoption d'un projet de loi
relatifs au retour des travailleurs
immigrés dans leur pays d'origine
et puis le gouvernement a également pris
note de l'échec des négociations entre
le patronat et les syndicats sur la
réforme de l'indemnisation du chômage
monsieur boulin le ministre du travail a
d'ailleurs annoncé cet après midi qu'il
présenterait au parlement avant la fin
de l'année un projet de loi-cadre sur
l'indemnisation du chômage le déficit de
5 à 8 milliards prévus pour l'année
prochaine serait financée par une
participation plus forte de l'état et
par un relèvement du taux des
cotisations
enfin à ce conseil des ministres par
parenthèse le prochain se tiendra à
marly-le-roi toujours à ce conseil des
ministres de ce matin donc il a été
décidé que la france serait candidate
pour l'organisation de l'exposition de
l'an 2000 à paris ce matin à vichy s'est
ouverte la conférence nationale de
l'aménagement du territoire il ne s'agit
pas d'un colloque secondaire puisque
l'on s'efforce d'y déterminer le visage
corps à la france dans les dix
prochaines années
organisée à la demande du président de
la république avec sa participation
d'ailleurs cette réunion rassemble
pendant deux jours à wisches
l'ensemble des parties concernées chef
d'entreprise syndicalistes élus locaux
etc
d'ores et déjà il est sûr que cette
conférence marquera un tournant dans
l'action publique sur la géographie
humaine de notre pays que sera demain
l'aménagement du territoire avec
pierre-marie thiaville voici un exemple
concret le territoire ce n'est pas
seulement le parvis de notre-dame le
territoire de la france en voici un
morceau c'est dans le massif central
mais ce pourrait être ailleurs
et il suffit de regarder ce paysage à
demi vide pour comprendre comprendre qu
aménager le territoire ce n'est pas
planter une tour de plus à l'orée d'une
grande ville s'est s'inquiété aussi de
ce qui se passe ici et ici comme dans
les centaines d'autres cantons c'est
l'exode rural qui continue c'est une
activité qui se réduit illustré par des
entreprises comme celle ci trois hommes
dans une petite scierie perdu dans un
paysage trop grand pour elle et qui
jadis pourtant nourrice et des centaines
de personnes une clientèle vous avez la
forêt qui juste derrière vous avait de
l'espace pour vous à grandir si vous le
désirez alors qu'est ce qui empêche
votre entreprise de se développer et
créer de l'emploi
cette saison ont fait 16 ans un premier
handicap c'est le froid et la neige
un deuxième c'est l'impossibilité de
recruter une main d'oeuvre jeune la
moyenne d'âge de notre commune et des
plus basses je crois 65 ans alors ce
qu'ils nous permettent pas de trouver
une main d'heure
vraiment jeune pourquoi cette moyenne
d'âge est elle aussi élevé les jeunes
continuent à s'en aller d'ici du tout
les jeunes sont partis depuis 20 ans est
actuellement dans la commune même c'est
impossible de retrouver un jeune qui
veulent travailler en finale il y à du
chômage partout dans la région mais ce
petit patron ne trouve personne parce
que hors de sa commune il ne sait pas où
s'adresser
il suffit parfois que lui rendre visite
un représentant de la datar qui lui
connaît bien le marché de l'emploi dans
toute la région
première action ça va être l'aider à
bien définir le besoin qu'il a démontré
une action sera de l'orienter vers un
centre de formation un conteur sud
d'apprentis futur six heures qui
viennent de d'être monté ambert et qui
répondra sans doute à son problème
mettre en évidence et en contact
l'offre et la demande là où elle existe
est un premier travail il y en a bien
d'autres
prenons un autre exemple une entreprise
industrielle celle là toujours dans le
puy de dome un robert une affaire de
confection pantalon et blue jays en
grande série 150 salariés l'entreprise
marché bien elle pourra embaucher encore
et ce sera un précieux dans le pays
encore faudra-t-il l'aider un peu au
début et ensuite lui éviter les faux pas
d'une croissance trop rapide
là aussi la rencontre peut être
fructueuse entre l'homme de la datar et
le chef d'entreprise
nous avons doublé notre production en
deux ans au début est ce qu'il ya des
incitations des primes qui vous aide
vous et ombres exane nous avons
bénéficié d'une prime de développement
régional après le démarrage d'une
expansion qui peut être aidé par une
prime
il faut continuer tout seul et à ce
moment là il ya une fragilité financière
non oui et nous souhaiterions peut-être
que l'environnement financier qui
entoure les petites et moyennes
entreprises soit peut-être revues ou
réajuster mon intervention surprise
était simple j'ai suivi le dossier de
près niveau régional pour qu'il
aboutisse rapidement et ensuite
maintenant que c'est fait mais acquise
et que l'entreprise continue son
expansion
eh bien on accompagne les entreprises
pour réunir le financement nécessaire à
son
à son développement trouver un ouvrier
six heures pour leur décrocher une prime
régionale pour l'autre la datar est bien
loin des spectaculaires opérations de
naguère comme fos sur mer par exemple à
cette orientation nouvelle il faudra du
temps et des hommes et il faut espérer
qu'on les y mettre et alors seulement on
pourra parler d'aménagement du
territoire de tout le territoire
cette conférence donc sur l'aménagement
du territoire s'achève demain avec un
discours important du président de la
république
retour au football maintenant avec
l'événement de la soirée sur antenne 2
il n'y a pas eu de miracle à duisbourg
les allemands ont gagné le match retour
des huitièmes de finale de la coupe de
l'uefa
et c'est eux les allemands des devises
bourque iront en quarts de finale
strasbourg a été éliminée 4 à 0 richard
diot un seul but suffit à strasbourg
pour se qualifier car au match aller en
france et d acier ont obtenu le match
nul 0 à 0 et là ce soir non seulement
strasbourg n'a pas marqué de but mais
duisbourg en revanche on a réussi quatre
si ce score de 4 0 est un peu lourd pour
les français qu'on connaît depuis la
victoire allemand ne souffre aucune
contestation
voici les quatre but 33e minute sur une
offensive de tous les attaquants de
duisbourg vorm le 9 battre au psy
irréprochable jusque là
deux minutes avant la fin de la première
période sur un centre de jarrat weber le
11 mystifie la défense concède dropsy y
compris et duisbourg même 2 0 à la mi
temps ça va déjà mal pour les français
la seconde période est à peine commencé
que les allemands aggrave la situation
déjà compromise des français et c'est un
3 0 grâce ou à cause de foule suivant
points de vues en classe car ce but nous
a paru hors jeu
enfin un quart d'heure avant la fin sur
un centre de vorm weber anéanti les
dernières illusions des français 4 0
pour les allemands strasbourg est
éliminé c'est fini non seulement pour
strasbourg mais pour le football
français qui ce rapport présenté dans
les quarts de finale des coupes d'europe
au mois de mars prochain
saint-etienne et bastia n'ont pas été
remplacés strasbourg n'a pas encore la
dimension européenne et les allemands
sont toujours plus forts que nous trois
autres résultats définitifs nous sont
parvenus ainsi mönchengladbach a et
qualifié battant rock lo 4 à 2 du cloud
prague est qualifiée face à stuttgart 4
à 0 c'est le seul faux pas d'un club de
la république fédérale allemande
à noter également la qualification des
retards berline face à hedberg 4 à 0
ainsi trois clubs allemands de l'ouest
se sont qualifiés ce soir
bien pour être complètement reste à vous
donner les pronostics de pierrette brès
pour le tiercé de demain dans le prix de
picardie à vincennes pierrette a choisi
idéal quito le dise iris de wendel le 11
il erra le 16 10 10 le 14 liant un
levain indien rapide leucate et ilmari 8
10 11 16 14 24 8
quelques mots de la météo et les
prévisions météorologiques pour eux
demain il y aura une zone de nuages
abondant et de pluies faibles qui vont
affecter les régions de bretagne de
basse normandie de vendée de poitou
charentes l'aquitaine les pluies seront
localement précédé de neige ou de
verglas en normandie dans les pays de la
loire et dans le poitou sur les autres
régions le froid persistera avec
cependant un peu de soleil dans l'après
midi
vous retrouverez comme d'habitude
patrick poivre d'arvor pour votre
journal de 20h de m'asseoir et puis avec
l'aude à la fin du programme vous
donnera tout à l'heure un résumé des
principaux titres de l'actualité je vous
souhaite une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2